hey guys merry here at PAX Prime 2015
and we're working with the mix to bring
you guys the latest and greatest indie
games I am here with Alex from heart
machine how's it going going all right
very good I'm doing pretty good and we
are seeing a game I actually saw also
last year but you guys are showing new
stuff and I love seeing everything you
guys have because this game is beautiful
it's hyper light drifter yeah thank you
yeah this game is stunning everyone's
really looking forward to it so let's
get right into it you guys are showing
us just a new area something I I haven't
seen yet yeah this is a the eastern
region I'm gonna break some crap on the
floor yeah please look two things for
people unfamiliar who haven't seen this
game yet give us the rundown of it oh
well there's exploding vine plants like
that okay it's a it's an overhead action
RPG you know there's their similarities
the link to the past but its its its own
unique flower there's a there's a lot of
really dangerous that's going on in this
world yeah constantly wants to murder
you it's gonna be very careful about it
you guys have beautiful animation style
but what I really enjoy about it is just
the gameplay of it you have a melee
attack but then you also have a ranged
weapon and your kind of using those in
tandem based on the various enemies that
attack you this game is not easy this
game is actually quite difficult a lot
of stuff comes at you and you can fall
off the world why not like add in more
stuff that can kill you so it gets
pretty challenging yeah I mean it's more
the vein of Dark Souls as far as
difficulty goes there's there's nothing
like that i mean i'm a professional
player at this game and I get hit all
the time you can see there's a lot of
details in this game that you guys added
that I love you'll notice that the
player as you get more injured you start
bleeding there's actually blood coming
out of you and hitting the floor just
like another visual clue that you need
to get health or play better it's funny
to play a better this game takes some
concentration so I might die
a couple of times while trying to talk
yeah it's it's a hard game to play on
talk so when we we played this on
gamespot last year the first round and
we were trying to talk while playing it
it's so annoying and this is a later
area so it's probably harder yeah some
seeing new enemies I've never seen
before uh murderous ninja frogs ninja
frogs that shoot death stars at you and
a lot of times another thing that you
guys are doing is you're you're opening
doors through various keys that you have
to find throughout the levels or on the
block so you're unlocking various levels
as you go around you have this little
companion guy he hangs around sure ghost
he's your dick obat yeah you can think
I'm more like a mag from phantasy star
online he hangs around and opens up
little passageways and hack stuff and he
finds some secrets and he tells you
you're dying also that's right so he
gets a little there's another visual
clue there's so many visual clues
throughout this game to guide you and
help you out in addition to you bleeding
all over the map your your little helper
guy starts blinking a Red Cross to let
you know that you need health as well he
also helps you unlock doors and guides
you in case you need it he might also
reveal some secret passageways at some
point all right that's right I promise I
can beat this area without dying again
those frogs are no joke
or I'll fall off um so you're finding
that you're actually dodging a lot in
this you are invincible for a little bit
for like a fraction while you're doing
that no you're always able to kill
ability yeah right so cruel cheap no
skins there's no none of that a role
dodge stuff this is more like you just
have to be very tactical right and this
is the campaign version but there's also
actually isn't there like a horde mode
where you're basically just hanging out
and enemies just keep filtering in yeah
we have a good little demo that we do
that shows and like wave after wave of
enemies because we have a lot of enemies
in this game turns out we originally had
like no man we had so many more I mean
we cut down quite a few because that's
how you don't need that minute you had
too many enemies and you got out of your
game with too many crazy unique enemies
so what else can we expect to see
besides ninja frogs in this area you can
see this guy right now ah that is a
massive frog yeah he's hungry you've
interrupted his breakfast see if I can
beat this while talking
nope oh man you one shot here yeah so
this guy's kind of a bastard he's
actually our easiest boss in the game
right now nobody's being a mom he didn't
dude suck was stressful what's he
throwing at you he's throwing these
little flame jars these explosive flame
jars and then he's trying to smash you
with his gym
but you can do that all right he's
bleedin yeah oh I'm gonna try and make
it look easy and you're mixing up your
attacks here you're doing a mix of melee
you're using various guns kind of shoot
them up and stuff I have two weapons
equipped right now all right those
change throughout the game I also have
that little grenades always the same
know you'll you'll get other equipment
throughout the game right now I have my
pistol and railgun
he's very angry now he's flashing red
dead homeless did it all right we'll
give it one more shot more try I can I
think I can talk and beat him I think I
can do it oh he's really he's really
hungry and you've totally disrupted his
breakfast wouldn't you be mad and try
and smash somebody if you interrupted
their cereal very stressful and you know
even though the gameplay is very
stressful and hectic and this boss fight
is just very aggressive I always find
the music quite calming and relaxing you
guys did a really good job with kind of
blending really intense gameplay
mechanics nice light-hearted visuals
that are easy on the eyes and calming
music it helps balance out the times you
probably want to throw your gamepad or
quit and brings you back in there yeah
good mix Richard breeland's astor case
has been doing the music and there is
there's a certain tonality to it is very
atmospheric but then in situations like
this of course it's appropriate to be a
little more angry with music and now
he's fast oh my god and she smashed me
that's it it's a pretty good example of
how freaking hard this game is yeah but
also how beautiful and how addictive it
is because you will always find yourself
coming back for more and I found myself
dying countless times in the previous
demo that I played but i still love this
game so much it's always good to see it
it always makes us angry playing and
when we die but we come back to it
anyway sometimes it's the angry games
that make you the happiest yeah so this
has a release window for next spring uh
yeah spring 2016 all right so you guys
can find it there thank you so much Alex
for showing me the latest version of
Hyperlight drifters that was hyper light
drifter you guys be sure to look for it
you will see it out on stores on steam
starting on steam and then it will start
filtering to other platforms ps4 xbox
one yeah alright so for the latest games
be sure to stay tuned to gamespot com